People didn't want to talk to me very much after that.
It was a pretty difficult time.
You know, it's the last race of the year; you don't have a chance to redeem yourself.
We lost the championship by one point so I tried not to be too hard on myself, but yes.
I am very hard on myself,...
...especially since this is something that doesn't leave your mind very quickly.
My failure?
I almost failed out of high school twice.
I had a really bad year where everything went wrong.
Oh yeah, everybody makes mistakes.
It broke all the bolts and the structure basically collapsed.
Well, I made a formal apology.
I can remember when I was out at the go-kart track one day.
You use the stopwatch and time the lap and...
...I remember I kept giving myself like 1 second less like,..
..."Okay, was that 41 seconds that time?"
"Was that 40 seconds that time to get around?"
I like to be able to see the improvement and with racing, it's very obvious.
You know, I can see the direct result of my effort.
We were in Homestead, Florida.
And this was my first IndyCar race, then there was a crash.
I didn't remember anything; the car was on fire and...
...my brain was covering up for the fact that this is a...
...bit of a heightened situation, that I shouldn't be aware what's going on right now but...
...I woke up in the medical center and there was a bright light above me and...
...Father Bob is over here to the left and I've got needles in my arm.
So, that was probably the worst moment.
If you're driving your car and you feel frightened a little bit,...
...we bump up against that feeling...
...as much as we can to try and push that limit further and get comfortable there.
And then push it again.
You're constantly on the brink of crashing 'cause that's the fastest.